Hello!
Hey, Dad's here!
Let me turn on...
Let me turn on the lo-fi for us.
Let's see.
Whoa!
It's a little too loud for me.
Might not be loud enough for you guys.
Today I feel a little bit...
A bit a little comfy today.
Let's see.
Oh, maybe it is loud for you guys.
Let me double check.
Oh, okay, let me turn that down a little bit.
All right.
That should be better.
Hello.
Why am I short?
Because I want Dad to be here for a little bit.
That's why I'm short.
I just want Dad to be here for a little bit before I kick
him away.
All right.
Goodbye, Dad.
Apparently.
Apparently the dragoons didn't want you here.
Bye.
That's what they wanted.
No, I was wrong.
Oh, you want him back?
It's too late.
I kicked him out.
It's too late, dragons.
You missed the thing.
You didn't know you missed the thing.
And you wanted the most.
One guy.
all right i was hydrating i ordered my new headphones today
um it's gonna be arriving tomorrow uh i'm feeling a little
i'm feeling very comfy today um at least just because i'm
like really tired uh in general i think like uh usually uh
whenever uh when i'm like in a mindset where i'm like oh the
day is over my mind just goes straight into like it's time
it's almost time to and I'm like, oh, thank God.
And I'm like, I forgot.
Now, I didn't forget, but like, I think like I
subconsciously, subconsciously was like preparing at events
to like be in like relax chill mode.
And I'm just like, I'm ready to, I'm ready for my two rest
days, definitely.
I think like this week has been, this week's definitely been
a lot this week.
A lot of stuff has been going on behind the scenes.
And there's like a lot of things to do.
I think like lately this week, I've been definitely sleeping
more because I've been feeling a lot more mentally tired
from a lot of work that's been going on behind the scenes.
I'm so sorry.
I was getting a lot of like people asking about the
whitelist.
We've stopped whitelisting for the last two days because we
thought that we would have the server up by now.
So like we were just preparing the Minecraft server.
So I'm so sorry for those who are still Tomorrow we have we
did not set up by tomorrow.
We haven't set up the server yet We're gonna be posting a
new way to like a Google form if if we don't have the server
up We'll be doing like a Google form for it, but we'll see
There's just so many things going on also form.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you I'm really sorry for those who are still waiting
We are still there was like a lot of stuff going on Behind
the scenes at the moment, but we have stopped white listing
I think like two days ago yet and you're still waiting on it
um you might have to wait a little bit longer because we are
currently going through some little things in the behind the
scenes regarding um setting up the discord server for it so
i really appreciate your patience everybody um and yes i
know i haven't uploaded the new outfit the the the skin to
reveal stuff oh that's why i'm looking forward to um i'm
really looking forward to uh the next two rest days because
i'm pretty sure I'm like right now I feel like really tired
yeah there's a lot a lot going on at the moment so um that's
why I've been like I've been like super I guess like more
tired than usual uh for this week because I think this week
has been a lot that's been going on um in the backlog for
behind the scenes so uh definitely gonna be days to just
like catch up on stuff as well as uh because like i don't
know it doesn't seem like it because i do still keep my
stream consistent um so like i try to i still try to like
stream consistently even though i know like there's a lot of
stuff going on behind the scenes um i don't want to
sacrifice i don't i try not to sacrifice uh my stream time
with you guys um and everything um so uh like like on stream
i feel like i got my shit together but after
off stream doki is a different is a different circumstance
um um yeah um so uh I'm really looking forward to the two
rest days uh but I'm glad to just you know end the week uh
end the week, uh, to, with Good Night Dragoons, just to,
like, hang out with all of you guys.
We're, we're, like, much more comfy, much more relaxed
today.
Uh, it's, uh, so I'm just, I just like talking with you
guys, you know, just giving you guys little updates and
stuff, and, like, just doing a little sat-sadon and
everything.
Um, Eric, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, today was definitely a day.
Had to run back and forth all over town.
Not fun.
Thank you.
Uh, next day, thank you for the Super Chat.
It's been a busy week.
Get some rent.
You deserve it too.
Thank you.
Think of the Super Chat.
Thank you, Nexi.
I really, really, really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
But yes, if, though, if I do feel tired after the second
rest day, I might take a third rest day in the row just to
make sure that because I can feel my brain.
I can feel my brain being very slow.
Like, I could I could definitely like feel like like the
cogs in my brain turning really really slow at the moment so
i definitely need to rest oh my god oh my gosh oh what do
you know like what i've uh what i've like noticed though um
what i noticed like uh recently in the in the recently in
the coming like not sorry i can't word right now like i said
my brain has been like really really slow um the last couple
of days um but like what i've noticed uh the last couple
months was that i've been like super unfiltered i i
literally i literally called pikachu a fat fuck i was like
oh my god i would have never called him that in the past i
would have been like he's a chunky little boy but i was like
no he's a fat fuck
um like old like old pikachu design i i realized like past
doki would have just been like oh he's a chunky little boy
no i'm like fat fuck and i spoke with like i spoke with so
much passion for that um i really I've been like so
unfiltered the last couple of months because like I guess
like you know when you're in indie I don't have to worry
about being like super careful about what I'm saying and
like being like I guess like Making sure I don't like I
guess oh, what's the word?
Making sure that you know, I don't see I'm making sure that
I don't say anything that would like offend people too much
because I have been like in the past would be like oh no
what would nintendo think if i called their main pokemon
mascot their main goddamn mascot a fat fuck
well like back then you know during the 1990s his original
design um like sponsor sponsored friendly um but honestly
Like, I realized, you know, ever since, like, um, becoming
an indie.
Um, yeah, yeah, no, Pikachu lost a lot of weight.
No, I, no, he did.
The reason why I said that was because I was like, oh, yeah,
guys, Pikachu used to be like this chunky.
Now look at him.
Now, like, every, every 10 years, he gets skinnier and
skinnier.
Like, every, every 10 years, they keep making him skinnier.
oh I was looking up like I was actually looking up like old
Pikachu designs I was so okay I was like oh my god they they
actually did they just like they just made him like like oh
sorry he's back I forgot to that's gonna pop in and out I
love I think this is my favorite okay uh I realized I binded
I binded dad to the wrong I call binded dad to the wrong
place so uh you're gonna see really soon like right now uh
and then he's gonna be gone in three two one
anyway um i was like looking at like old pikachu designs and
i i love somebody to meet this comparison um i i i love like
the progression of like i love it was like 1995 and then
like what fucking happened 2018 2018 he turned into
minecraft pikachu turned into minecraft uh no it's i don't
know if you guys remember this but this was 2018 was there
um was nintendo's uh mobile games uh phase where they made
like yeah it was like blockachu they made a uh well not
minecraft but like what's the word they made like a like a
block version of of uh pokemon for like an iphone game for
like an uh not an iphone but because it was also on android
but for like a phone game the mo yeah they had a mobile game
nintendo had a mobile game phase um where uh were like they
made a bunch of Nintendo games because like Nintendo games
on the phone because it was like the next big thing um so
one of them was like what if Pokemon were like blocks that
were sort of shaped like Minecraft and also we can
merchandise that and make them into like sort of like um
off-brand Lego blocks for Pokemon and also made them into
plushie form too like the thing about Nintendo is that like
games are not what makes the money now it is merchandising
not just nintendo but like pokemon pokemon's like biggest
income is not video games because they know you guys they
know people buy whatever fucking pokemon game comes out it
doesn't matter
um don't lie to me like whatever they make you guys will buy
um you see i i broke out of that programming i haven't
bought a poke okay jk never mind i bought legends of arceus
because they actually tried a new formula but other than
that legends of arceus is like their their actual they went
out of formula but other than that i didn't buy any other
pokemon game i still buy their merch because like um i've
broken their video game programming but i haven't broken
their merch programming i still buy pokemon merch um
Pokemon is less of a game company and more of a merchandise
company now.
So that's why everything they do is incredibly calculated in
a way that like what makes the most, what kind of
merchandise would make the most, like what kind of design,
what kind of product would make the most money.
Like that Pokemon Sleep app they did, they fucking instantly
made merchandise off of it.
They instantly made like the what was the sleeping Pokemon
merch out of the app that they did.
And people bought that shit.
People as in me.
I bought a sleeping Pokemon plushie.
And also Pokemon cards.
realize like Pokemon cards they they actually make it much
more what's the word they make it much more uh less scalp
they try to make it as less scalpable as possible uh because
uh I know like they like limit people on Pokemon card sales
so that kids can actually own the cards as well so they made
it more affordable for and actually more like harder to
scalp compared to like other other stuff they do because
like you know they don't want to you know they try to make
sure that it's affordable like you know it's still a company
for children like to appeal to the kids so they still want
the kids to be able to afford it and to be able to
experience it um so that's something that they're really
good at doing um um yeah you can't buy no you can i'm pretty
sure you you can buy boosters or i guess not like whole box
of boosters you're just limited um you're limited to like an
amount of packs you can buy uh brainwash them early yeah i
mean other companies do that like
why do you think like faster restaurants started to do like
play areas like it's not a new thing like why do you think
like there's play areas in fast food in fast food places was
to make sure like the children were there and like like and
then like toys too like the the fast food toys that you get
I used to remember the ones the the Burger King ones with
the um with the poke the gold Pokemon cards and then there
were like you know that's where how I got introduced to Neal
pets because of the uh because of the toys that they were
handing out in like fast food um but that's what that's
basically it it works you think ronald mcdonald was made for
adults like like like it works like like um anyway what was
i gonna say oh my gosh i don't know why i don't know how i
got into the oh yeah yeah the reason why i got into uh i got
into this tangent um was that it definitely feels nicer to
be able to like you know be able to criticize things and uh
that that was like my whole point of the tangent um that i
can actually like criticize stuff when needed and like call
out things what um being able to call things out and form
opinions on stuff because it's like you know um i feel like
what's the word i keep thinking like what's the word because
i'm trying to like formulate a better way to explain this
um i think it's very healthy to be able to criticize stuff
um because like if you're if you don't have any opinions if
you're always trying to like uh be as pd g as possible then
i think that's boring i think that's really boring of a
content creator because like you know the fun thing is also
like you get to banter with your chat about different
opinions you have about like uh like you know because i
called like paramount ugly and then you guys were like no
he's not i'm like yeah he is he's literally a thumb with
wings and
banter with you guys about like um about stuff and like
seeing like different opinions on things um and uh palmi
ugly is such a strange take though because he is ugly i i
don't understand he's he's just like a fucking blob he's
like a potato and the eyes aren't even cute as all at all
please don't make me go back into the tangent of how ugly
padamon is
It's not just, okay, it's not the fact that he has simple
design.
There's simple designs that work really well.
But Padamon is not one of them.
It's literally a potato.
It's a giant fucking orange potato with, like, a bat wings
stuck on its head.
It's not, the eyes aren't even cute at all.
The eyes are, like, like, what's wrong with their eyes?
But we got our own opinion.
Yeah, but Mama Shiba.
Mama Shiba is different.
Mama Shiba, at least it's a dog.
It's like a dog peanut.
That's different.
Dog beans are different because it's part dog.
And anything that's part dog is good.
You're wrong and that's okay.
and and they say fun facts chat they mama shiba mama shiba
gives you fun exciting facts that expand your brain okay
sorry i i got i i i can get i get way too passionate about
this uh simpson thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you um what else i was gonna say but you know it's it's nice
to be able to i guess like speak freely on stuff like you
know if i don't like something i can be like yeah that
sucked like yeah i could be like yeah that that was i could
be like yeah i didn't have great time playing doing this
part of the game or like yeah this is a poor or this is like
you know this is garbage like this could have been improved
on so it's nice to be able to um be able to criticize and be
able to form opinions and like um you know be be able to
express my thoughts and i realized like lately i've been
like super unfiltered like lately it's usually in the past i
have like filtered myself a lot like i have filtered myself
a lot in the past and i try i always like think about what
i'm people think that i actually don't think about what i'm
saying in in the past but i actually did um i actually try
to make sure like i don't say anything that was like sort of
like a brand risk and be like less opinionated on stuff
because like when you're part of when you're a content
creator um um when uh you're well of course i have to still
be careful of course because like i still want a career um i
still i still want a career but i've definitely like
definitely loosened it up i've loosened up like what i say
and like what i say to you guys and like what my thoughts
are on things and but like definitely in the past i have
like restricted myself a lot to keep like a lot of my To
myself, when it comes to, like, oh, if I didn't like
something, I wouldn't say it.
I'd just be like, oh, yeah, like, if they can approve this,
they should do this instead.
Like, I did.
And I'll be like, yeah, I did have a good time.
And then inside, I'll be like, I didn't have a good time.
But I can't say this game is garbage.
I can't really say this game that's made by a big company
was dog shit.
But I'll power through it.
I wouldn't send you in, not say it directly.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dad deserves a good night.
Can we have him back?
Thank you.
The super chat.
All right.
Here's Dad for like two seconds.
Say hello to Dad for like two seconds.
One, two.
Goodbye, Dad.
Woo.
it was it was definitely a video game
um but it's nice it's nice i still try to make sure you know
um i do try to be very careful uh when it comes to like
stuff i say uh because you know i'm still a content creator
and as a content creator you have like you know an image and
to to like you have an image to keep clean and uh You do
have to be careful with stuff you can and can't say.
And I'm just here to make you guys have fun and laugh,
basically.
I just want to, like, turn off my brain and just hang out.
And hang out with my dragoons.
And just, you know, have fun, laugh, and everything.
Um...
Let's see what else.
Uh, Madeline, thank you for that one gift and ship.
Thank you.
Oh, my gosh.
You know, like, when we were playing...
When we were playing Digimon World, I remembered, I remember
there was like one game.
I was like, oh my god, I really want to play Monster
Rancher.
I actually, I used to play, uh, I used to play a lot of
Monster Rancher, uh, growing up.
Um, but then like, my dad also bought the Japanese copy of
that, so I also did not know what I was doing.
Uh, there's like a, a habit of that, I think it was Monster
Rancher 2 on the PlayStation 1.
Was it 2?
It had to be 2.
But, because I saw Monster Rancher 1 and it looked, the
graphics on that looked like worse than Monster Rancher 2.
I need to make sure.
I think it was 2.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Also, I love the anime too, Monster Rancher.
But I remember my dad bought me, or I don't know if he
bought it for himself.
I can't tell.
think he bought it for himself because a lot of the games
that i played in ps1 was just my dad's hand me downs so i'm
pretty sure anyway monster rancher for those who don't know
what monster rancher was um it was basically like digimon
world but like the monsters weren't digital uh and they
could also talk so like they they weren't pokemon because
like the monsters and monster rancher actually die they
didn't like fake die they like die and they can talk to you
um they didn't have hot monsters in monster ranchers so
there was no rent so i'm sorry guys but there was no angel
woman or like angel man um in monster rancher they were
actually monsters um so i think that's why it wasn't as
popular as digimon because they didn't have like they didn't
have the digimon yeah what's the point they didn't have the
digimon turn into like hot i guess like angels so so it
wasn't as popular as digimon um but
so like um it was big it's just like it's just a farm for
monsters and you like raise them and like you fight use them
to fight other monsters and everything but yeah i used to
you trained them you raised them they can die um but i
remember playing monster entry too um as a little bird and
um i didn't know what's going on because my dad was had the
japanese copy of it um so like i had no idea what was going
on so i was just pressing random buttons but i always love
seeing the monsters run around the track and like going into
the barn to sleep that's all i could remember i that's
literally all i could remember from um uh from the game but
i had a good time i had a i had a good time um um let's see
Dark Blade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Doki and Dragoons.
I'm at a restaurant called...
What the fuck?
Okay, I'm at a restaurant called BJ.
Should I get a pasta or a burger?
Thanks for your response.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You should get a burger.
I had a pasta last night, so I don't want you to eat the
same thing as I did.
So you're going to eat a burger.
Pasta night is my Pasta night Not your Pasta night So So you
should get a burger Thank you for the super chat Thank you,
thank you Let's see Next see, thank you for the super chat
Thank you, thank you Are you saying you aren't into any
Monsters?
Thank you for the super chat Thank you thank you um that's a
wild question to ask me and on unlike good night dragoons
like that's an incredibly wild question to ask me on on a
supposedly like chill lofi relaxing stream
I don't think I'm gonna give that answer For just $10 Thank
you for the super chat Thank you, thank you Let's see What
was I going to talk about?
I should have a list of topics that I wrote down Oh my gosh,
okay This is going to get a little like mushy here But like
I also like Also Definitely needed to the rest day To to
rest Okay, this is gonna get a little like I'm opening up
myself a little bit Guys, so it's gonna get a little mushy
here So I'm gonna like Open myself a little bit Like open
myself up a little bit Oh well, money is the issue Okay I'm
sorry I read it in And the next thing, thank you for the
Akasupa Thank you, thank you Oh, money is the issue
Thank you for the Akka soup, but thank you, Nexi.
All right, before we get on to that, there's no other reason
why I definitely need to take more rest days.
I had to take a back-to-back rest day.
Was that, oh my gosh, okay.
All right, this is why I told my mods, because I was like, I
messaged my mods about it, really worried um but sometimes
okay i'll let you in okay guys we're gonna we're gonna oh my
god you guys would be like oh my god that's so sunday like
okay look okay um the last i think like the last like two to
three streams um that i did um last two to three streams i
did i like message my mods like uh like uh one or two of my
mods and i was like was i too mean That is like, oh my god,
guys, was I, was I too mean to the dragoons?
Like, do you think I was too mean to them?
I hope, like, I hope like the dragoons know that I was just
joking around.
Like, I was like, oh man, I hope they know that was just,
uh, that was just like joking around, and I didn't really
mean that.
and so they're like no no it's okay they like that I was
like oh yeah sure I don't know I feel like I was like
sometimes sometimes you know it's like um I feel like I
would be like I felt like I went too far this time are you
guys sure I was like I'm not too mean
so so so the last like two to three streams i actually felt
like i hope i wasn't like going too far with like my jokes
and stuff so i was like oh my gosh i feel like i was like oh
my to my mom i was like i felt like i went too far do you
guys think i went too far like i don't know i don't know if
they actually thought that was funny or like if i was just
if like i actually offended people
Oh my god I don't remember what it was that like made me a
loop into that because like sometimes I go into this like
loop where I'll be like oh no did I like go too far I was
like I'll be like looping at a lot over and over again
because I'll be like oh no did I did I like did I uh uh push
too far there
I don't remember what it was that I don't remember exactly
but like the next day I'll be fine I'll be fine the next day
but like I was getting to I'm not always but it was like a
two to three for like the last two to three streams I was
just like oh no was I that I'd go too far this time
um um oh yeah it was definitely definitely in in neopets
where you know where I was like be sick I was like, you're
like, oh, you got neopox, good.
I think, okay, now I remember.
It was the neopets portion where I named the neopet dragon.
And I was like, and I threatened to pound you.
I threatened to throw you into the pound.
And I was like, oh, no.
Did I go too far with that?
now I remember I always like I always like forget about it
the next day I always forget about it the next day but it
was definitely like something in the last two or three
that's why I was like oh no if I've had these thoughts if I
start having these thoughts I'm gonna like eat myself alive
like it's gonna eat myself alive so I was like oh maybe I'm
just like tired like I that's why like that's why I was like
okay I definitely need um back-to-back rest days because if
I start having these thoughts that means I'm like really
tired like I'm like that I'm like I'm really tired to the
point where like I'm actually like overthinking it and like
um and being content creator the worst thing you can do is
like overthinking and um um it was it was just like me
overthinking it being like oh no if i like overthink this
and i like second guess myself that's not good so i
definitely needed the rest so that's why i'm taking the two
back-to-back days and if a third day if needed if i'm still
like in that like mindset um after the second day so um but
yes guys sometimes you know sometimes um uh
okay look guys I might make you starve sometimes but like it
is with good intentions
look I just need you guys to know that it is with good
intentions chat
um um hats thank you the super chat thank you thank you i
cannot get over how cool your new skin suit is thank you the
super chat thank you thank you i'm really glad i'm glad you
guys uh i'm glad you guys uh like this new skin suit like i
said when we're when i've been like planning the new skin
suit and everything that was like i don't know if you guys
could find it in like a couple like you know a couple of
months ago in avod where i was like oh yeah i just finalized
the design i'm so because branding is everything like um and
um and like i'm just really happy that in the end like
everything came out like good and people that the reception
of it was great and everything like a lot of my worries are
definitely like god so i'm i'm really happy about that um
Okay.
Bapapap.
Noroko.
Thank you.
The super chat.
The same much.
But I hope I can bribe you to promise that you will rest as
much as you need.
Thank you.
The super chat.
That's why I am going to, I am going to try and rest as much
as I can.
And also catch up on some work in the next two to three
days.
Depending on, depending on how I feel after the second day.
But it's nice.
I always like doing these.
and streams because i can you know relax unwind myself uh
just like have like real talk with you guys and like uh you
know just enjoy each other's companies um kaz thank you for
the akasupa thank you thank you we're being mushy anyway
today is my first year anniversary of discovering you um i
don't even watch vtubers before that so thanks for
incredible times off to another year thank you for the
akasupa thank you thank you i really appreciate it um it is
actually crazy i've i remember like doing the panels uh
doing some of the panels uh in the various conventions i
attended the last couple of months and i think like two of
them i had like bark knights showing up and it's actually
really crazy to see sometimes because like there was not a
lot of bark nights like I There wasn't a lot of bark nights
So it's really insane Sometimes to like be able to like Have
some of the like Like original bark nights Coming in and
being like oh I I watched you all the way since then Like
I'm an OG bark night And everything I don't know if you guys
know This but um Back then uh during like the bark nights
time um i we would i would like send like uh a lot of the
bark nights like um they there was a collection i think it
was like i'm trying to remember how many i printed out um i
got maine but like there's one person okay each month i
think like before like uh you know
I think like the last six or seven months for six to seven
months.
Each month, the top, was it top 10?
It was like top 10 donator or subscriber when I used to do
Twitch, when I used to do Twitch streams.
So it was easier to track this.
And there was not a lot of us.
So it was really easy to track this.
But it was like, I think it was like five or 10.
I guess like donated slash gifted uh gifted subs would get
like postcards uh with postcards uh uh being like the top
supporter of the month and uh I remember I would I do stuff
like that obviously I can't do that anymore because there's
a lot of us now but back then um to show my appreciation um
because like uh I don't even know guys know this but um
during the bark nights time um even though i had like like
30 like 20 to 30 average viewership um obviously like my
average viewership went up a lot because i did like partner
push but it was because like i did a lot of there was a lot
of lurkers so i did a lot of partner pushes uh because it
took me like like i got rejected like three times so and you
have to wait like I think like two months or something to
reapply again it was I didn't I think it was like one or two
months I don't remember it was so long ago um but yes I'm
pretty sure there's like somebody uh they're still fans I
know I have a lot of bright night stars still here that
still owns the last like six to seven like the seven month
postcards of the whole collection of them um and everything
just to like show my appreciation and stuff but it's always
crazy see um that there's like a lot of fans that have came
from years years ago that are still supporting me to this
day and i really appreciate it and the new fans too um i
really appreciate all the new fans and all the old fans and
all like um fans who've just started watching me and they're
still watching me i really appreciate because like every
every one of you guys um do so much even if it's just
watching me um it's like you guys support me a lot uh and
you know keep me relevant
because as a content creator that's that helps a lot you
know that helps a lot um let's see uh where was that uh uh
uh simpson thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
uh my fellow goons and dokey should i order the big cheese
it crunch wrap supreme or the regular crunch wrap supreme
from taco bell it's free either way i don't know i've never
had taco bell i don't know whichever one makes you use the
bathroom less because that's the only thing i know about
taco bell um is that you um is that is that something you
eat where you have to use the bathroom um so which I guess
like whichever one does it less like don't do it it's gross
it's fast food like you know what you're getting when you're
at fast food restaurants like like like it's not like it's
healthy for you like you know what you know what you are if
you're ordering a taco bell
you know what you sign up for oh my gosh um let's see i'm
looking at my list of stuff i wrote down um oh my gosh it
was actually really funny um oh right after like the neopet
stream right after the neopet stream there's like so many
things that just popped in my head and i was like oh why did
i talk about that like i was just like remembering like the
history of neopets and um and everything because i wasted so
much of my life on that website and um i was like
remembering how uh how there was like the underground i was
funny i was like talking about like the underground black
market for neopets i mean to be fair there's an underground
black market for a lot of video games um there's like i
won't be surprised if there's and World of Warcraft, but I
know that wasted, well, like, I lost my main account.
So, like, I feel like I could say that as somebody that's
lost your main account that got cookie grabbed.
Oh, for those who don't know about the Neopets Black Market,
the Neopets Black Market was basically like any other video
game Black Market, similar to the Mercy Skin Black Market,
the Pink Mercy Skin Black Market.
At one point in time, there were pets called the Unconverted
Pets.
For those who are like, what do you mean by that?
Well, Unconverted Pets are, oh, sorry, I need to play my
lo-fi music track again.
because all the songs are done.
But basically,
back then, they did a thing where in the past, they would
use original art.
They would use original art for each Neopet.
And because of that, each Neopet had, like, each special
Neopet had its own, like, unique pose, unique, like, unique
pose, unique experience.
expressions and everything um unique artwork for basically
almost every uh design and every like pet but then um later
on uh when uh when you know it got owned by different
companies when like the original creator meal pets sold the
company um it went to a group of people who were very into
profits and into like it got onto the public stock market so
people got really really into you know try to make as much
profit as they can off of neopets and one of the things they
did was that they basically made it so that um they change
the art style of neopets to a point where every um every
design of a neopet had a fixed pose um it had a fixed pose
and a fixed like um standard like a standard default
expression because they started selling cosmetics and called
uh and they opened a thing called the neo mall and neo cash
so neo cash was obtained by with real money and and back
then you don't
just meal points and uh they did that so that they could
start uh monetizing they can start monetizing uh cosmetics
and stuff where you can put like backgrounds by backgrounds
by outfits and everything um there was much more
customization to it but it ended up making the pets really
ugly
so um because of that they only it only hit the 99 percent
of neopets users so because of that the 1% of pets did not
get converted into that into the newer art style so the 1%
of like pets there were like one person like very like some
owners some new pet owner will have all their pets converted
or maybe it was like all pets but one like like because you
only own four so like only one of your pet was not converted
into that art style so because of that that started the
underground the underground black market of people selling
new pets for thousands of dollars and obviously years past
um the longer the years passed uh the rarer it got because
sometimes you know people who own the pet um they uh they
their account will get frozen so like that pet was gone
forever you know like it was gone forever so um so so like
you know the really rare pet never to be seen again so some
of you guys are like oh it can't be that much of a big
difference okay i'm gonna like let me show you guys like the
big differences between all right the the um um the vet
neopet veteran players give me an example of like a really
beautiful pet ruined by the conversion
Which give me an example Like the best example you can think
of That was Oh the Halloween
Okay Alright let's see I like how everyone's like sure you I
don't even remember I wasn't a sure you owner I didn't care
about sure use as much as like Others The sure you wasn't
that bad.
I don't think I don't think it was as bad as like the other.
Oh my god everyone is like sure I think it I think it wasn't
that bad.
It wasn't as bad.
Let's see it was less dynamic.
Okay that's true because they're all just standing there.
In the past they would just like they would actually fly but
then they like grounded them so they would just stand there
um i'm gonna show you again it lost all their dynamic poses
yes i agree with that all right let's see okay but like a
specific one a specific style a specific like uh oh okay
okay i'll give you guys this one okay i'll show you guys
like what i mean um oh the fairy do you guys remember the
fairies we talk the fairies we talk were so pretty um all
right i'll show this fairies we talk okay so this is like
one of the pets uh where's the converted one though okay the
fairy sweet talk oh shit oops welcome back dad all right so
uh all right this is a good example all right so this is
like uh let's see let me clip this um all right give me a
sec dad we need to make sure you don't keep showing up all
of a sudden so i'm going to disappear first dad what are you
doing no i'm sure dad you can't keep you can't keep showing
up okay dad okay all right all right sorry um i closed the
door so so he wouldn't keep showing up oh
don't put him in the back all right all right let me show
you guys uh what i mean when i said they like basically uh
changed a lot so oh there's also this one too i guess like
i'll give use my mods example too because they're very
passionate about the halloween loopa uh because they're a
furry uh
um so so like this is what the i do not did not in that
state
okay so like um all right let me make sure i grab this
picture real fast i'm grabbing the picture now guys um uh
all right let's see so they're really passionate
specifically about the the Halloween lube because this is
what they used to look like and uh yeah like I don't know
how to explain it but like literally all I can say is yeah I
can't explain it in any other way like when you see it
you'll be like oh yeah that's why they they're sad that they
so this is what they look like before like this would be
unconverted and um the unconverted halloween uh lupe design
and then so and then after that they converted it and this
is what they look like after that so um so you know you can
tell why you can tell why you know they they people were
really mad about this
because especially because like um a lot of them a lot of
them they stopped what's the word they it's like when they
used to be like when they used to be like you know on on you
know two feet they regressed back into being like four feet
so people got really mad about it and one of the things one
of the designs that got hit the most is the royal paintbrush
because like it made the royal pets look really ugly in
general because people were like what the fuck like like who
put this halloween costume on them so i'll give you guys an
example so this Used to be called the royal...
Um...
The royal...
Uh...
Brush.
The royal boy brush.
So if you have a boy...
Boy Lupe, it would look like this.
So this is...
Um...
This is what they would look like.
And then...
After... After the conversion...
They would look like...
This.
Oh, where's the picture?
Come on!
Wait!
Wait, where did it go?
It just disappeared.
Okay, sorry.
I just get it disappeared.
Where did it go?
Oh my god, where did it go?
Okay, transform, reset transformation.
Wait, where the fuck did it go?
I like saved it and it disappeared.
Oh my god.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, this is what it looked like.
Sorry.
So, you know, People, people got really mad.
Oh my god, really?
It converted.
Oh, there was an invisible brush too.
There was, oh, JL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Okay, yeah, I saw there are the furry bros on this bad
conversion of Lupe.
They just, you know, it's like they, they, they got a dog
and they gave it a fake beard and everything.
um so um so that's why people got incredibly mad about this
because you know they're like i didn't spend millions of neo
points just to have my fucking majestic royal royalty dog
turn into an actual dog we have one yes of course I'll show
you the fairy The fairy guys got hit the hardest The fairy
and okay So you know how I said the The gray pets The gray
pets were Like people really love the gray pets Because
before then The unconverted Gray pets Oh yes also like all
the lupes started making suggestive eyes Which made up some
people uncomfortable Anyway because you know they're like
Literally dogs like But one of the biggest nerf was that the
gray pets, the reason why gray pets were like really, really
valuable was because they were one of the most expressive,
one of the most expressive designs out there.
So I'll give you guys an example.
These, the brush used to be very, very expensive because
they were like one of the most, you know, they're depressed.
so but they were like one of the most expressive designs out
there so like this is what this side bunny would look like
before and then and then the conversion happened the great
conversion happened and this is what they turned into like
now now he's just gray like he's not actually sad Like, I
can't feel the depression anymore Like So people got really
mad about it Cause they're like Why isn't my pet As
depressed as it was before So people got like People People
got really mad about that Alright, here's like Here's
another one Like Um, oh my gosh, I'm trying to find one that
was like mega changed, like the one of the Um, biggest
examples of it.
Oh, here's one.
Okay, here's one of them.
This is like, okay, here's another one.
Um, because like they all, during the great conversion, they
all basically, it's like the same pose.
It's just, all they change was like the colors.
So people got really mad about it.
So here's another one.
This is a very sad horse.
Very sad, like, unicorn, Pegasus.
And they're called a uni.
That's, like, and then this is what happened during the
great, like, this is, you can tell, like, they're really
sad.
They're very, very sad.
And then, and then, this is what they did.
Now, they're just, you know, they got something in their
eye.
Like, God.
like you can feel the depression here um where where you
know like the the the horse you know hasn't really taken a
shower in a couple of days um their hair is a mess and then
this guy on the top during the great conversion um you know
they just they got something in their eye like they got
um that's why there was an underground there was an
underground black market for meal pets and people were
selling these guys like especially these guys for like
thousands of dollars in like real money because they're like
because these guys were like super rare to get and they're
like super expressive and everything yeah like the details
were just all gone and stuff speaking of like is that was
actually crazy i was looking through like um i was looking
through the new colors that they have in the old pets did
you know there's like the elder you can like make your pets
old now which i was i was i was so surprised about um
because like i did not realize like what i don't know i'm
just i guess like the role play will go super hard but I'm
like here thinking why would I want to make my pet old like
there's there's like an oh okay I need to show you guys
because I thought it was really funny when like I I thought
I thought it was so funny I didn't realize it was a real
thing um but this is uh this is like one of their newest
brushes which is like an old so you can make your pet
fucking old I'm sorry, it's so funny I thought it was so
funny I'm like, why?
But yes, you can turn your neopet into like I guess your
grandpa Oh wait, there's like Okay, let me see if there's
Let me look through these I need to look through the I'm
gonna look for three days Oh my gosh, this one's funny
There's like this one.
I'm just, I don't know.
I don't know what to say.
Like, I, I, I, I don't know.
Oh yeah.
And then, okay.
You can even like take off their clothes because like, I
don't know.
And I don't know why, but like you can also take off their
clothes.
So like, this is like what one, this is them clothes.
But then like, cause they're wearing glasses, right?
But then obviously you can It's only like the thing is it's
like only their their their face that's old and that's it.
So here's like an example like here's like what it looks
like but it's only their face.
Like I don't understand.
Like I guess like let me try like maybe I'll take out
clothes for the other ones.
Okay sorry the context for this is really bad.
But I just want to know like what what it would look like.
I guess like there's wrinkles on them um but like i don't
really see like what the difference really is other than the
face no don't take off their clothes oh there's like elder
okay there's one for like the female version of it too wait
let me show you guys the female version don't worry i didn't
take off, I didn't take off the clothes.
I just want to show you guys the female version of it.
This is the female version of a Pateri.
Look, there's Granny.
That's gonna be, that's gonna be us one day.
That's gonna be me.
But there's like the elderly brush too.
Anyway, the Neopets rabbit hole goes really deep, guys.
It really does.
uh there i i was re-watching the neopets vod too and like i
didn't even realize like there's a memorial i i was like i
was looking through the vod and i realized they added like
new things on the map and i was like wait there's a moon
like i saw this i saw why is there a war memorial like
to have a war memorial in my neopets game do you know what
this was okay do you know what it looked like before this is
what neopets looked like before that's why I was freaking
out I was like who told them to civilize like they used to
have no houses they lived in caves so I was like I was just
like who taught them how to build a bridge where happened to
my prehistoric lands what happened anyway like i said
neopets actually in the in the story of neopets like they uh
they actually um they can actually like die die so that's
why there's a war memorial and then this is what it looked
like before so i was just like oh my god they fucking they
learned how to build infrastructure.
Who taught these cavemen how to build infrastructure?
Soon they're going to evolve and learn how to drive cars!
They're not going to be the priest.
What was the point of painting them in the pure historic era
if they were just going to evolve anyway?
Like, there's a reason why I kept them in this era.
Oh, sorry.
Alright, moving on.
Moving out from Neo Pets.
I want to talk about something else, but I want to talk, I
haven't ever told you guys about this, but like, I actually
really like Monster High.
For those who are like, what the fuck is Monster High?
Um, I don't like the dolls.
I don't, I don't give a fuck about the dolls.
I just really like the show and the lore.
And like, I don't know if I ever confessed that before.
show the monster high show not the newest one not the newest
one the newest one sucks um and the movies the movies suck
but i used to watch the old style the original og monster
high style and like um ever after high i really liked ever
after high ever after high before they put it on hiatus
forever because it was not as popular as monster high but i
actually i actually used to your high and i really enjoyed
it i don't care about the dolls because like i know like
people uh what was it mattel is it has a mattel i feel like
it's always mattel
um um but i uh i used to i used to watch the show a lot and
also like the 3d animated movies before they went with the
newest style and um i really enjoyed it i oh it's hasbro it
was either mattel or hasbro i could never remember uh it
because like uh because like you know it's always like ran
by the two doll companies and it's either mattel or hasbro
but obviously like their main goal is to make merchandise
it's to make shows to like to make shows to to sell merch.
It doesn't matter how well the show does.
As long as people buy the dolls, that's all that matters.
The thing is, I think they for, I feel like Monster High,
like the creators of Monster High, like the, not creators,
sorry, Mattel for Monster High, I feel like, um, they didn't
realize that the reason why a lot of people bought Monster
High dolls They were really good for doll customization.
So people bought a lot of Monster High dolls just to
customize them.
And not because they want the dolls.
Because apparently Monster High dolls were like the easiest
to customize dolls with.
I don't remember the reason why.
But I have a guilty pleasure of watching like doll
customization videos.
and um and like they always used monster high dolls because
they always had like the best uh I guess like the best mold
for customization um and I miss monster high I would love I
love that show that was such a good show also ever after um
I oh my gosh I wish they I wish I wish they didn't reboot it
it was I don't know I really like the style I really I
really like this oh my god My feet VTuber is a girl.
It was so iconic.
No way.
Was I ever into Bradstor?
I was never into dolls.
I was never into like.
My oh, she's a woman?
Anyway, bro.
My bro tuber.
My bro tuber is a woman.
Anyway.
anyway um real female dokey uh dude bro uh what was i on
what was i on because before i got distracted there oh yeah
i wasn't into dolls i was not into like uh dolls in general
i honestly um the closest to like dolls that liked like you
know like actual like playing with dolls was littlest pet
shop littlest pet shop that's you whoa um i used to have uh
i used to buy a shitload of littlest pet shop figures and
like i had like the the big giant littlest pet shop um on
grooming station um with like you know the pet shop or like
you can like uh bathe the pets and everything and i would
buy like specific like i wouldn't like specific like pets as
well i'll be like oh that's a rare one it says it's the rare
one i want it and i would buy like a lot of the littlest pet
shop um the littlest pet shop uh figures and everything i
think that was like the closest to like figures i like not
figures sorry closest to like dolls i ever had i'm trying to
remember if i had like other dolls but i don't think i did i
usually i just had like i just really played with littlest
pet shop i played with littlest pet like video games because
like i'm i was like why the fuck would i play with dolls
when i can play video games you know like that was my that
was my mindset as like like as a child i was like why i
don't need to use my imagination if i if i had video games
like so so i like never really had like toys i guess like i
did have toys like i you know like interactive toys like um
i had interactive toys that was like supposed to like help
with like electronics and stuff like there's like one that
like the leapfrog thing where like it was a boat book that
teaches reading and stuff um so you can like get a pen and
then like like go over words and stuff and it'll be like
this is how to learn to read and stuff like that but like i
don't think i ever like i don't i rarely ever physically
played with toys um it was mostly just like video games like
game boys ds uh game boy vans consoles like playstation one
um playstation two uh no xbox because i said my dad hated um
xboxes um he only bought i told you guys he only bought xbox
once and once and it was for the 360 for some exclusive
shit.
I don't remember what exclusive was there for on the 360
that made him buy an Xbox.
Oh, Gears of War.
Gears of War was exclusive on the Xbox.
And then so it was like on the Xbox 360.
So it was the only time he's ever owned an Xbox 360.
Speaking of Xbox, the Xbox has the fucking worst naming
convention I've ever seen for a console.
Like,
1s like what what does that mean like it has it has such a
fucking terrible naming convention like i i why why is it
the newest one was it like xbox i'm gonna pull it up i was
like reading it i was like they released they released a new
new generation of xbox and it's like xbox what like the
series sxs one okay xbox console names okay the xbox series
s okay okay i'll show you guys why i think like the xbox has
one of the the worst naming one of the worst fucking series
of names i've anything the xbox series for those who don't
know this is like so there's the original xbox uh the xbox
360 uh the xbox 360 core the xbox 360 elite the xbox 360
arcade the xbox 360 s xbox 360 e xbox Xbox One Yolene, Xbox
One S, Xbox X1X, and then the Xbox One S, all digital
edition, and then Xbox, I don't know what this is, what is
this one, what is the new one?
So, I would, I never understand, I never, I never understand
Xbox, the Xbox series, X oh yes sorry that's the Xbox series
X so like how I'm just I'm like how do you keep keep up with
that like how how do you keep up with that at least like you
know PlayStation 1 PlayStation 2 PlayStation 3 PlayStation 4
and 5 PlayStation 5.
How the fuck am I supposed to remember Xbox Series 1X?
Like, how?
At least like at least Nintendo they had like the Wii U and
then like the Wii and then the Wii U You know and then they
scrapped the whole thing and was like we're making a new
console the switch I hope because if they make a new switch
that means there's potentially they'll finally fix the
they'll finally fix the analytics the maybe finally finally
finally the controllers will finally be fixed after that You
know, sometimes, you know, the Joy-Cons, they'll finally fix
the Joy-Cons after air.
Um, that's really all I want.
I want a new, I want a new Nintendo Switch console just for
the sake of finally Joy-Cons being fixed.
Uh, out of context, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Doki Bird, new skin name is X Doki Bird Doki Series D.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
It just reminded me of like, uh, of like the naming
convention.
Oh my god.
There was like the worst movie franchise names.
There was like a movie franchise that had like the worst
naming convention in regards to like the movie franchise.
What was like, there was like a movie franchise?
Is it Fast and Furious?
Yeah, Fast and Furious.
It's Fast and Furious, I forgot.
Yeah, it's Fast and Furious.
It literally reminded me of Fast and Furious movies.
I talked about this before, but if you guys did not know,
the Fast and Furious movies have the worst naming
conventions for a movie I've ever seen.
And for those who've never seen it before, don't worry.
I got you guys.
So, um, they basically, um, they also like to fuck around
with, like, different names.
And here you go.
So, there's Fast and Furious, or the classic.
Too Fast, Too Furious.
The Fast and Furious Tokyo Drift.
The Fast and Furious, back again.
Fast, Five.
Fast and Furious Six.
The Furious Seven.
The Fate of the Furious.
Where the fuck did Hobbs and Shaw come from?
That's, I did not realize that existed.
The F9.
And finally, the Fast X.
So, this is basically, like, this is basically, like, the
Xbox, but, like, much more elaborate.
The Fast and X.
But it was...
Okay, and then I showed this before.
But Fast and Furious, Japanese titles.
The Japanese titles was, like, also very similar.
So, this is...
Let me show you guys what the Japanese titles were for them.
I showed this before, but I'll show it again.
Because it's honestly one of my favorites.
things about it's it's one of my it's one of my favorite
things about the fast and furious uh movie franchise so this
is like the japanese titles of it so you can see they called
it wild speed wild speed x2 wild speed x3 wild speed max
wild speed mega max wild speed euro mission wild speed sky
mission wild speed ice break wild speed super combo So, you
know, they didn't care about the Hobbs and Shaw thing.
They went Wild Speed Super Combo.
And then Wild Speed Jet Break.
So...
At least he kept it consistent, you know, with the Wild
Speed.
At least...
That was consistent.
So this was like the titles of it in Japan.
And this just reminded me of X, like, Xbox reminded me of
this, because, like, Fast and Furious had, like, I don't
know, they just throw some words in there, and then, it's
just, they just, you know, throw some words in there.
Um, uh, let's see.
Uh, Dag, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
I saw somebody earlier asking about even about my opinion on
the game and Uh, uh, it wanted me to answer it.
So influx.
Thank you.
In a super chat.
In flux.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Hey, Doki speaking of your dad.
You mentioned he loved the Yakuza series, but you found it
too long.
So I suggest like a dragon again is shorter, but touches On
the previous game so you can get a feel for the series.
Thank you.
No matter what, I think reason why I have not I think I
talked about this before, but like, um, I don't touch the
Yakuza series because like Even though like no matter what
Their The yakuza definition of like short Is like really
Still really long
It's like a shorter version of yakuza But like it's still
incredibly long Like it's It's still a very very very long
game and it's like you have to dedicate like at least like a
month like sandland took us a while but sandland is actually
known as like what in the like it's a it's sandland supposed
to be like a short rpg um action rpg but even then like
sandland took us a long time
like i think it took us like a month and a half to finish
sandland so so it's like that's why I like I try to not um
try to put not try to uh not touch games that are like
incredibly long because I I know like my strengths and I'm
definitely like guys I can't read guys like guys your oh
she's illiterate guys so like we'll both struggle I swear, I
feel like, I feel like I'm making you guys more stupid too.
I feel like the longer you guys watch me, like I feel like
we both are like feeding into each other's illiteracy.
I'm making, I'm also making you as illiterate as me.
The longer you watch me.
Um, but that's why I tend to like avoid, uh, jrpgs because
like i know that it's not my strength and there's like a lot
of other streamers who are much better at streaming jrpgs
than me that's okay i don't i'm here to make sure you turn
off your brain when you watch me um no no thank you for
super chat thank you thank you uh and visual novels oh my
god you know like what else oh my god so like i realized
like I actually thought about it for a while, but I was
like, oh my god, I could potentially stream corpse party,
but then like, I was rewatching, oh my gosh, I was
rewatching corpse party a playthrough because like, I don't,
course, I used to like, course party was like super
interesting, but then I rewatched it, and I was like, I was
rewatching corpse party a little bit, and I realized like,
uh, it was a very long game like it's a it's i i was like oh
my god i forgot it's so slow
it's so and the writing the writing is not as good as i
remembered i feel like maybe i was like young i was like
really young because like guys corpse party came out in 2008
chat that's guys it is it is a very old game and i'm like
thinking i was like oh my god i must have been like i was
definitely like way too young to watch this
i was way too young to watch it and then i was re-watched i
was like watching like part like going through like a vibe
of it and then that's not that old that was like that was
like 16 years ago that that was 16 years ago they're like a
junior in high school that they they can they can drive 17
they can the game can literally drive now the game can yes
it was
whoever said whoever was like that's not that old um
the flow of time is cruel anyway anyway um by the way don't
want the anime for a course party I watched the anime for
course party it is it's really bad it's I don't remember I
don't remember much about it I just remember it was very bad
so uh and then I tried to watch the sequels the play game
like because like how many how many games has course parties
been Okay, there's Corpse Party.
There's...
What the fuck?
How many games have they made?
They made Batman...
Oh, no.
Holy shit.
That's a lot of Corpse Party.
What?
Corpse Party.
Corpse Party New Chapter.
Corpse Party Blood Covered.
Repeated.
Fear.
Corpse Party Book of Shadows.
Corpse Party Sweet Satchiko's Hysteric Birthday Bash.
Corpse Party 2.
Dead Patient Course Party Blood Drive Course Party 2 Dead
Patient Nexus Course Party 2 Darkness What are these When
did they make all of these Course Party?
What the fuck?
I didn't even realize there was that many Course Party
That's a lot more than I thought there was All I remember
was the original Course Party I heard like Um I try to watch
a playthrough of the PSP game that somebody when was it it
was a course party No, it was like was it book of shadows.
I try to watch one of the newest ones.
Oh, yeah, the PlayStation Was it blood drive?
It's not as good.
It's it's like I think because oh, yeah, they went with like
a 3d model I think it's always whenever they go like with 3d
it just starts being not as good
but oh my god it's actually uh yeah the chibi one where they
use like it's just because they use chibi models and like it
always feels weird when they like when it's just like
because it's supposed to be like this horror game and then
they use like like like um what's that style called the
original corpse party what was the style called the uh yeah
it stops being scary in the chibi style uh these corpses
party more than i do yeah the rpg maker yeah like the rpg
maker has like a charm in it where like um we're you know it
has such a charm in it for the horror genre that when they
started when they did the the chibi style to the horror but
also if you guys rewatch court's party um the writing you
realize there's like the writing for the game was definitely
filled with uh was not as great as i was like it was just
the part where like you know the writing yeah i was I was
why we're rewatching it I was like wait this was not as
scary as I remembered because there was like a scene it was
a really fucked up scene in there that oh is it like it just
has like scare I was rewatching horse party and like like I
was like there was a part in there and I was like you know
like one of the most scary I'm gonna spoil alert for it I
was I'll spoil like it was like a spoiler alert for it
because it's like a game it was just core it was very gory
like I think it i think that was it the reason why is that
like when you're like when you're especially when you're
watching it when you're younger or like younger um you're
really surprised because it was like the the anime style
like the anime cute style especially like rpg maker cute
style and then they show like gore and then you know when
you're younger you're like oh my it's like you know happy
tree friends you know like like like it's like happy tree
friends where when you're younger you're like oh my god the
gore stuff like that and and i remember like uh there was
that moment where spoiler alert there was this really
pivotal moment in there that was that basically changed the
atmosphere of the game where um they bumped into two child
ghosts and then they like threw one of the the students
against the wall and like she exploded into guts stuff like
that And then, you know, it was like the first, it was like
the first like in your face, um, in your face moment where
like, shit, this game is real.
Like, yeah, yeah.
And like, you know, that was like that scene left in and
prepped.
Like that's literally like there's two scenes that I
remember.
Cause like in chorus party, I literally only remembered two
scenes from there.
like the most fucked up moments like like i was like they
added that into the game one of them was that one the second
one was where i thought i was like i i remember when i was a
kid i was a kid when that happened when i watched when i
watched that playthrough as a kid and i was like what the
why is it here why was this And then, you know, as you got
older, you realize why they made that scene.
But it was when the little sister kept being like, I need to
use the bathroom.
Like, and that scene, like, as a child, like, I was like,
why?
Like, and then, yeah.
Those were the two scenes that, like, imprinted in.
my mind it was literally like the only scenes i remembered
like oh my god they were the only scenes i remembered um
because they were left like a fucking they left like oh my
god like um and then so then i like rewatched course party
because i used to be like obsessed with course party back
then like a lot of people were super obsessed because it
course party every youtuber every youtuber um streamed it
every not streamed it did a let's play of it it was like
what was it it was the purple i i know i was at the oni oh
my gosh what is it the that other rpg game it was the ioni
um that course party um the witch one the witch's house was
that one of them that's what it's calling uh uh mad father
uh what else i think that was like uh bender ib oh yeah
there is ib and then yeah these were like the i mean like
the top the five games that were going around like rpg maker
games were so popular back then and these were like the five
ones that kept everybody kept fucking doing let's plays of
so then like i remember i was like i really i like enjoyed
the playthroughs of that and like the lore and the story of
all of that and then so like i remember i was like and
course party was one of the only games that kept having
sequels for some reason like i don't know if you guys know
this but every other rpg maker game at no sequels or like
barely any sequels and course party was literally the only
game in the one of the only games in that genre that had
like a million sequels going in like so so like we everybody
would always like keep up to date with it like so that's why
like I don't know like they would have like anime
adaptations several anime adaptations might i add um and uh
and then yeah and then like looking back to it uh looking
back to it like re-watching the gameplay of it i realized it
wasn't as good as i remembered it was definitely not as good
as i remember i'm sorry like it was scare gore factor
because like what the other games lacked was the gore part
of course party and like the shock factor of it and but the
other games did not have that that's why people were like oh
my god
um yeah i feel like you had to be there at that time like
similar for uh yeah it was just it was very memorable for
the for the time it was released because no other rpg maker
that was popular at that time like that was super popular at
that time had the gore that course party had
so nowadays um oh my bgm stop sorry a lot of those now
there's there's definitely a lot of those um yeah it's just
it's nice it was um it was like just like a memories moment
there uh what was i uh what else do i want to talk about
today um That's nice though.
It's nice like going through like memory lane and just like
rethinking back about like the type of games that were like
super popular like 10 years.
Not 10 years but like more than 10 years by the way more
than 10 years.
Playing random indie RPG maker games.
The thing is, there's like, it's very rare to find good RPG
maker games.
Uh, good RPG maker games nowadays, I feel like.
Um, it's just, because like, there's always like ads and
trends when it comes to certain video games.
Uh, and, um, and RPG maker, you know, you have to...
to be there at around 2010 to like be there for the RPG
maker boom uh where like there was a lot of there was a lot
of uh a lot of RPG maker games that had really really good
story and really the art might not be like as good back then
too like the only reason the art improved was that it gets
like re-releases or HD remakes but it was like a bunch of
like small town small time artists like
it for their own free time and stuff um but it was like an
interesting time back then i think now the current fad right
now is someone oh yeah by the way uh i saw that somebody
asked me if i was gonna be at evil i cannot confirm or deny
it that's that's all i'll say
I think like, I think like, um, the current gaming fad right
now, the gaming trend right now is, I'm trying to like think
of like what new games, I honestly think currently the
newest gaming trend is fighting games, um, due to like, uh,
a lot of stuff.
Oh yeah, by the way, I thought it was so funny because it
popped because like you know i follow like uh from say jam
slam i follow like a lot of people on from from say jam slam
on twitter so like i saw the one about um that video about
how some like uh pro player for one of like the fighting
game tournament is through a chair and like destroyed a
lighting equipment that was worth four thousand dollars or
So, like, they subtracted their earnings, and now he has a
negative earning.
I thought, that was so funny.
So this guy won a fighting game tournament, but, like, he
won barely any money.
He won barely any money from that fighting game tournament.
And he celebrated by throwing a chair behind him and, like,
destroying this lighting equipment that was worth, like, I
don't know, like...
A lot of money.
So now on his like Liquipedia On his like pro player Pro
player Tournament earnings sheet He has negative earnings.
Yes He was the first winner Ever In a In like as a pro
player To have a negative $2,000 Overall Earnings Yeah Wait.
Ma, do you have a...
Do you have a video clip of it?
I saw it on Twitter.
I was like, what the fuck?
Yeah, actually.
And then somebody was like, that was like not even a good
win.
Yeah, like people were saying like...
He didn't, like, the matchup wasn't even, like, that great.
Like, he didn't.
Um, all right, let's see.
He didn't fully commit to the pop-up.
Basically he won the dead.
All right, let's see.
I'm gonna see if I can, let me see if I can find the video.
I just love the Twitter comments the people like roasting in
they're like it wasn't even like that good of a pop-off
though I was just like it was so which I thought was the
funniest part let's see if they updated oh they didn't okay
I want to see they updated oh they deleted oh they deleted
his liquipedia that's sad wait that's actually sad why did
they what did they did wait they deleted this liquidpedia
wait did they actually they he used to have it like he
literally had a liquidpedia i saw it i saw it too and it's
like it's gone oh my god they actually deleted it that's so
funny Oh, yeah, because the prize, oh, yeah, okay, this is
why, okay, um, all right, so I'm gonna show you guys, okay,
wait, is it JPEG?
God damn it, why is it always a web?
All right, I'll show you guys the picture, and then I'll
show you guys the clip, well, I'll link you guys the clip,
not show you guys the clip.
Uh, let's see, where is it on Twitter?
Where is it?
Oh, here you go.
Uh, we're gonna fuck is the pop-off i want to see the
pop-off clip oh sorry not the pop-off the fucking by the way
the prize money was literally 500 so people were like what
so they were like this was not worth it um there we go this
is the this was the video clip and like this was the let me
grab the screenshot this is a screenshot of um how much
money he lost so basically like it was a three thousand
dollar light and he literally just won five hundred and
sixty five dollars so he actually he no but the reason why i
said just five hundred dollars is because he literally broke
a lighting equipment that's three thousand dollars like
that's why that's why people were like people were like what
the fuck i wish i had saw i wish like um i saw the tweet
about like uh i wish oh my gosh i wish somebody has that
where is that tweet it was so funny i saw it was i saw the
liquefedia entry too and they literally gave him like
negative like they literally wrote negative amount on this
Liquipedia page and it got deleted it got deleted they
actually believed the
name they deleted their Liquipedia also the reason why like
it's sort of easy to tell um um it's sort of easy to tell uh
um what is like the current gaming trend you just see what
riot's doing um so they're currently working because like
the thing is like uh riot is really good at figuring out
what is the newest gaming trend and like what to capitalize
on what to develop i don't know if you guys saw this but
they do they canceled a what was a platform fighter but
they're releasing a they're releasing a new fighting game
with like uh they released uh a new fighting game to um uh
to capitalize on like the fighting game genre um so what is
it the 2x ko i just think like fighting games right now is
currently the most popular gaming trend at the moment um
because there's always gaming trend a couple of years ago it
was battle royale now we're dying and now it's it's fighting
games right now especially like competitive wise i feel like
competitive wise also i'm pretty sure riot is uh going into
the fighting game genre so they can like uh so they can
capitalize on like fighting game tournaments as well because
like esports because they uh what riot is really really good
at is making games for competitive esports uh and i feel
like i'm pretty sure they they went for it they went for the
new fighting we went for fighting game because they want to
get in on the evo action as well as like other tournaments
that they can host themselves as well um yeah they're pretty
yeah they're really good at uh they're really really good at
uh at running like e-sport events and stuff in general so
i'm not surprised about that uh they're really good at
figuring out what games have like good esport potential
um yeah I just think like that's the current trend when it
comes to gaming um FPS is gonna die out like uh like RTS
we're gonna die the FPS is gonna die out soon just like RTS
uh
say it ain't so We're gonna be just like them We're gonna be
just like them RTS has new games Like what?
Name me Name me one right now That has like That has like an
actual player base That's not less than like That's not Like
less than like 5,000 players.
What else am I going to say?
There's an upcoming RTS.
It's just going to die out in like a month and you know it.
You know it.
I like I say Whoever said Solaris That's not an RTS
Someone's very passionate about Solaris Oh my gosh There's
something on mine But I forgot God damn it I hate it when
you have like a thought in your mind And you just forgot Oh
my god What was it?
No I don't remember I don't remember I No, I don't remember.
Oh, oh.
I saw, like, what is it called?
I wrote it down in my calendar.
But they're opening up a...
There's a new game.
Early access is coming out.
Concord, yeah.
I saw, like, people were playing Concord this week.
Because it was an early access.
It's, like, the newest Call of Duty slash...
Um...
It's, like, basically Call of Duty with different heroes.
And, um, I was, like, thinking about it.
We all know it's going to die in a week.
But, like, we all know it's going to die in a week.
We, we all, yeah, we all know it's going to die in, like, a
week or so.
So, but I'm just, like, wondering if I should try it out.
Um, I'm going to play, what is it?
I'm going to play Marvel Rivals, though.
I asked the dev team to get the, uh, to get a code for
Marvel Rivals.
So we're gonna, I think beta is opening next week.
Yeah, beta, uh, the next beta test is opening next week.
So I think I'm just gonna, because I was like debating why I
should try Concord.
But I'm like, oh my god, that game, I'm sorry, but that game
looks so boring.
Concord, Concord looks so fucking boring.
Like, I can't, like, I was watching it and I'm just like,
it's just, it's just colored, It's literally like they put
they try to be like it's they try to be like it's a hero
shooter but like um but they make it call of duty style so
it's barely like a team shooter it feels more so of just
like um it feels more so of just uh call of duty with heroes
yeah it's basically call of duty with heroes but it looks
worse than call of duty so like I don't know I was watching
a bit so I was watching shroud play it was a shroud no I was
watching I was watching lyric play it was literally like the
most pop like you know like when most the biggest streamer
the biggest streamer that was playing it at that time so
yeah it looked oh yeah it looked like destiny 2 pvp yeah i
agree it looked like destiny 2 pvp so i was just watching it
and i'm just like i don't know it doesn't seem like it had
anything new to the formula so it's just it was just like
space call of duty i guess like but then space call of duty
is basically destiny pvp so like how could they improve on
that when destiny already has it for free so so
most likely most likely i'll just be playing marvel rivals
next week i might i might play some marvel rivals next week
i'm thinking of like um i don't know maybe i'll try um uh
play more rank on it too Maybe.
But I'm not sure, though.
I feel like...
We'll see.
We'll see how I feel.
Anyway, I just realized it's been two hours.
Oh my god, I've been talking for...
I've been yapping for two hours.
Oh!
Oh my god.
We had like...
This week, I felt like I streamed a lot for this week.
Not gonna lie.
I streamed a lot this week.
So maybe that's why I feel like more tired in general.
But it has was...
It's been a great time.
Just talking to you guys.
Just hanging out and having conversations with you.
you guys uh um and honestly um wait I oh yeah I didn't
purposely avoid the monster question guys I actually forgot
I actually forgot um what was the original question let me
look back at it just so I can answer um correctly all right
where is it um nexi someone says are you she said are you
saying you aren't into any monsters all i'm saying is that
all i'm saying is that fuck okay
that's it anyway as always everybody stay hydrated posture
check get up and move around to get flowing and if you
stayed up for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see
you guys next time everybody bye guys